Wednesday Adams has gotten a makeover
and some vocal fans aren't happy in
their opinion her name should be changed
to Mary Sue Adams instead with her
deadpan wit Gothic wardrobe and
affection for all things Macabre
Wednesday Adams is an outcast icon
popularized by Christina ricci's
portrayal of the character in The Addams
Family films of the 90s the teenage
nightmare has recently received a modern
makeover now played by Jenna Ortega in
Netflix's Wednesday the character Sports
a fresh new fringe hairstyle as well as
some new priorities compared to her
predecessors when Wednesday opens
Wednesday has just been expelled from
Nancy Regan High School for unleashing
piranhas on the Water Polo team as a
result she enrolls at a new school
called Nevermore Academy while this
Edgar Allan Poe inspired school for
outcasts may seem more her speed
Wednesday nevertheless insists on
staying away from the pack and only
focusing on her writing cello playing
and solving a mystery that plagues the
academy grounds however well Wednesday's
many talents may make for entertaining
television what summer character Rising
as a lack of realism has soured certain
viewers on Wednesday's character in the
show's early episodes for a
self-described loner Wednesday Adams
seems to participate in plenty of
extracurriculars in Wednesday before
entering the halls of Nevermore
Wednesday is an accomplished cellist
author and fencer she then continues to
prove her talents in each of these
activities as the series progresses
certain viewers however have criticized
Wednesday's competency and her wide
variety of interests as presented at the
show's outset describing her as an
archetypal Mary Sue in fiction the Mary
Sue archetype is a main character who is
incredibly well liked and competent and
without any noticeable flaws in a thread
they started on the Netflix subreddit
about the first three episodes of
Wednesday one user wrote the all-knowing
ever so handy at everything Wednesday
Adams it's like I've Seen It All Before
and it's just so meh on the same thread
another redditor replied I knew before
she even touched the bow and arrows that
she was going to get a bullseye first
shot super predictable Mary Sue for sure
another Reddit user wrote that the
degree to which they found Wednesday
state to be more of a caricature than a
three-dimensional character made the
show hard to watch for them additionally
people on Twitter have described the
character as a Mary Sue explicitly that
said most of these Impressions seem to
be based on the start of the series and
have elicited plenty of pushback against
this idea that Wednesday fits these
so-called Mary Sue archetype in response
to criticism that Wednesday Adams is a
supposed Mary Sue at the start of
Wednesday a number of users online have
countered that Wednesday becomes plenty
three-dimensional as the show continues
where are your whiskers ask again and
you'll be down to eight lives for
example in a Reddit thread that
criticized Wednesday based on the first
three episodes of the new Netflix show
one user countered after watching the
whole thing she is far from being a Mary
Sue instead she's deeply flawed another
user similarly argued that Wednesday's
Independence ultimately proves to be a
character flaw down the line on Twitter
people have also written that Wednesday
does not qualify as a Mary Sue as
talented as Wednesday is her character
still runs into conflict as Wednesday
continues past its opening few episodes
Wednesday is constantly challenged
especially when No One Believes a fellow
Nevermore Academy student by the name of
Rowan was murdered her biggest hurdle
meanwhile is her struggle with empathy
Wednesday's true failing as it turns out
is our inability to connect with those
around her how she progresses through
this struggle ultimately becomes one of
the show's focal points while initially
the ultimate Outsider Wednesday
overcomes her internal struggle by
accepting people into her life by season
one's end
foreign